สวัสดี ฉันชื่อ Katy Besdalo
ฉันเป็นผู้อำนวยการด้านกลยุทธ์ IBM Quantum
และการวิจัยแอปพลิเคชัน วันนี้มาหักล้าง
ความเข้าใจผิดเกี่ยวกับควอนตัมคอมพิวติ้ง
ให้ได้มากที่สุดใน 60 วินาที
ควอนตัมคอมพิวเตอร์นั้นเป็นของจริงแน่นอน
และตอนนี้เรามีอุปกรณ์บน IBM Cloud ที่ทุกคนสามารถเข้าถึงได้
ใช่ แต่สำหรับงานบางอย่างที่มันทำได้ดีจริง ๆ เท่านั้น
เช่น คณิตศาสตร์ซับซ้อนมากแบบที่จักรวาลขับเคลื่อนอยู่
แต่ถ้าอยากทำสเปรดชีตหรือส่งอีเมล ใช้
PC ของตัวเองดีกว่า
ในทางทฤษฎีใช่ แต่ยังไม่ใช่ตอนนี้
ยังต้องรออีกนาน ยังไม่มีใครสร้างคอมพิวเตอร์ที่ดีพอ
สำหรับสิ่งนั้น ในอนาคตอันใกล้เรายังอยู่ในเส้นทาง
และเมื่อถึงจุดนั้น เราจะเปลี่ยนวิธีที่เราปกป้อง
ข้อมูล
นั่นผิดอย่างสิ้นเชิง ควอนตัมคอมพิวเตอร์
แตกต่างกันโดยพื้นฐาน
และใช้กฎของธรรมชาติในการประมวลผลข้อมูล
AI ในปัจจุบันทำงานบนอุปกรณ์คลาสสิกแบบเดิม
แต่เราเชื่อว่าทั้งสองจะทำงานร่วมกันในอนาคต
ไม่จริง เรามี ecosystem ที่แข็งแกร่งมาก
ทั้งสตาร์ทอัพ มหาวิทยาลัย ห้องปฏิบัติการแห่งชาติ และพาร์ทเนอร์อุตสาหกรรม
ที่ใช้อุปกรณ์ของเราทุกวัน
ไม่ใช่ quantum-inspired นั้นมีมา
นานแล้วและทำงานบนอุปกรณ์คลาสสิก มันจะ
ไม่มีทางส่งมอบสิ่งที่ quantum computing สัญญาไว้ได้
ถ้าอยากได้ quantum computing จริง ๆ ต้องทำกับ quantum
คอมพิวเตอร์จริงเท่านั้น